[Music]
at roughly 1 pm on march 13th in the
ukrainian city of mariupol resident
denise malihin records video of russian
forces striking apartment buildings
throughout the residential area around
him about an hour later less than a mile
down the street another resident timor
rudolph films the same attack on the
neighborhood as he and others take cover
between these two locations a photo
posted the day before shows remnants of
what military experts say is a cluster
bomb a weapon that can cause
indiscriminate civilian harm
they're all fragments of evidence that
have prompted u.s officials to accuse
russia of committing war crimes the wall
street journal verified videos and
photos posted to social media analyzed
satellite images from maxar technologies
and spoke with military strategists and
residents of the city to reveal a series
of russian military strikes on civilian
locations
mariupol is a southern port city that
had a population of around 450 000
before the war it's strategically
important linking russian-controlled
parts of eastern ukraine with a swath of
territory the kremlin has captured in
the south
the jof-nevi district in the western
part of the city is one of the areas
most decimated by russian attacks
the journal pieced together satellite
imagery analysis from the united nations
and our own data to show the extent of
visible damage
footage shot by timur rudov about a year
before the invasion indicates that this
is a civilian district
we can see a shopping center
apartment complexes
a public square
a maternity hospital
and a theater
in the four weeks since the invasion of
mariupol began all of these places have
been obliterated
targeting civilians is a playbook the
u.s government says russia has used in
chechnya and syria the international
criminal court's definition of war
crimes broadly include willfully killing
causing suffering or deliberately
targeting civilians the russian embassy
in washington dc didn't respond to
requests for comment the kremlin has
said that it is not targeting civilians
now we see civilian locations being
attacked in mariupol
russia has denied using cluster bombs in
ukraine more than a hundred countries
have joined a treaty that banned such
weapons though neither ukraine nor
russia is a signatory
these types of munitions release many
submunitions or small bombs as they fly
which can cause widespread civilian harm
in tightly populated areas
on march 1 mariupol's city council
posted photos of missile debris in a
residential neighborhood in other photos
of the same debris munitions experts
said this tochka ballistic missile is a
cluster bomb the nose cone and tailpiece
of the missile are intact and didn't
leave large impact craters indicating
they separated before impact to release
a warhead containing smaller bombs the
city council shared another photo of a
russian submunition steps away from the
missile debris further evidence that
this was a cluster bomb according to
munitions experts
attacks on civilian locations in
mariupol began with russian forces
hitting civilian infrastructure
they struck electricity plants and took
out cell towers
in early march we can see multiple
attacks on mariupol's food supplies
video posted march 3rd shows a
smoldering home improvement store
smoke billows from silpo a major grocery
store across the road
satellite imagery days later reveals the
entire shopping center in ruins
about a mile away videos posted to
social media on march 5th show the
city's largest mall port city home to a
grocery store cafes and a movie theater
was also hit
a satellite image from around the same
time shows the entire mall has been
flattened
a video posted later shows the damage
inside
after targeting basic infrastructure
russian forces hit houses and apartment
buildings leveling large swaths of
residential neighborhoods
about halfway between the two burned
shopping centers we see a wide view of
damaged four and eight story apartment
buildings in a satellite image from
march 12th
in a photo posted to social media the
same day munitions experts say we can
see the remains of a second band cluster
bomb in a public square nearby
experts say the intact tailpiece
indicates this is the same kind of
missile confirmed in other cluster
bombings in ukraine
around it are a pharmacy restaurants and
shops
the next day timur rudov and his
neighbors take cover as the apartment
buildings around them are hit
other videos posted to social media that
same week show widespread bombing of
homes in the area
on march 19th timmer assesses the
destruction of a neighbor's apartment
as russian forces struck residences they
also began bombing places like hospitals
and shelters
where residents including children had
gone to seek refuge
here footage shows the aftermath of the
march 9th bombing of a maternity
hospital which killed three people and
injured 17.
we can see this crater which explosives
experts say is indicative of an air
dropped bomb weighing at least a
thousand pounds
this woman and her baby died days after
being rescued according to the
associated press
nearby the hospital local mikhail
porteshev who regularly evacuates
residents from a bomb shelter there was
filming the hospital attack when his
location came under fire from the air
foreign
outside a school across the street
and an office building and cafe behind
him are destroyed
less than a mile away from the hospital
on march 14th a satellite image reveals
the word children written in russian on
the ground outside of a theater
signaling civilians to anyone flying
overhead
there were more than a thousand people
hiding inside
the azov battalion a far-right
paramilitary group that was absorbed
into the ukrainian national guard posted
a video to telegram showing people had
taken shelter there
then on march 16th this video shows the
aftermath of the russian bombing at the
same theater
[Music]
satellite imagery taken afterward shows
vast destruction
municipal authorities later said more
than 300 people died in this attack
local officials estimate over 5 000
civilians have been killed
on march 28th the city's mayor called
for a complete evacuation as the attacks
continued